there are those on the right who want
you to believe
that because Donald Trump is being
indicted the system is broken they point
to the Trump indictment and say see this
is the problem with the country are
institutions aren't trustworthy we are a
nation in Decline this is all bad
and they couldn't be more wrong the
indictments of trump prove that at least
at this point in the process no one is
above the law they love to say if they
can do it to Trump they could do it to
anybody we knew that they could do it to
anybody and we know that when we say
there's a two-tier justice system we
talk about the wealthy and Elite with
access to the best lawyers and unlimited
money for defenses and everybody else we
knew about the two-tier justice system
they want to tell you the two to your
justice system is left Wingers and
right-wingers there is no evidence of
that